[Music]
breaking news tonight a fourth set of
human remains has been found at lake
mead national park service says the
skeletal remains were recovered at swim
beach this afternoon thanks for joining
us at 11 i'm vanessa murphy park service
rangers were called to the area today
around 11 15 and were assisted by the
metro police dive team
[Music]
human skeletal remains found at lake
mead national recreation area saturday
morning this marks at least the fourth
body found at the lake this year as the
water level continues to drop the first
in may near the shore in hemingway
harbor we heard a woman scream
from
the side of the beach and then my
husband went over to obviously see what
was wrong
and then he realized there was a body
there and a barrel metro police say the
person may have been murdered in the
late 1970s or 80s because of the clothes
he was wearing later that month near
colville bay more remains found a
possible drowning victim between 23 and
38 years old according to the clark
county coroner this man telling the 8
news now i-team he believes this could
be his father who drowned in 1958
consistently
each clue is putting us closer
and this is like a bullseye and then in
july additional remains found near
boulder beach so far none of the four
bodies have been identified yet
right now the clark county medical
examiner is trying to determine the
cause of death of the remains found
today all of the investigations in all
four cases are ongoing